today's about you guys uh appreciate you
guys for coming out thanks for having me
if you don't mind taking a moment and
maybe tell your background tell
everybody about your podcast and then
we'll get right into it yeah you want to
go first you go first me first let's go
look at that
yeah okay figure out
rock paper scissors
often never duplicated go ahead
yeah so um they called me fresh from a
pressure podcast um i'm 29 years old i
used to be in tech used to do
programming and coding as well and uh
basically um i used to do youtube prank
videos so i started doing videos on
youtube like gold digger pranks all
these pranks videos stuff like that and
uh i did an interview with a friend of
ours and uh connected us together he
spoke on an hour-long phone call
regarding dating lifestyle money success
and he said hey you know what let's do a
podcast
you guys had never met prior to this
never met before and this is how long
ago by the way this is paul like you're
not you know yeah going on almost two
years now so you guys have only known
each other in less than two years yeah
wow so much yeah we met through another
youtuber shout out to our guy solo tv 84
he uh linked this up together got it all
right as you were well yeah and then um
we spoke for our had similar like
mindset and we did the first podcast it
did pretty well you know uh we did one a
week and then two a week then three a
week and it became what you know today
freshman fit and then our after-hours
show uh we went on a double date late
night and we were like late we're like
oh you know what we're in the studio two
girls let's do a late night podcast with
some girls and surprisingly it blew up
from there and uh started the after hour
special that we have today so the one
time we were like lit because me and
fresh don't really drink but on this
night we we were drinking and fresh was
like bro you know what he's like looking
at me like all like blinking like this
and that's how you know he's saucy he's
like
we should go live right now and i was
like what i was like bro we don't have
our producer here because he likes the
one i switched the cameras around
everything was just us he was like let's
just do it man i was like all right all
right i guess we'll do it all right
whatever so we did it and people really
enjoyed it and then we just kept going
and this was back i think january of
2021 because we started the podcast
october of 2020 and then we did that
first episode with girls january of 2021
and then yeah uh with girls and then
that's what people kind of like like
that's what made the channel grow really
fast and then from there people came for
the girls right they came for the tits
in the ass and they came then they
stayed for us after so you know people
have been like they'll come in watch the
girls they're like oh wait you guys have
content on like making money and you
know also like getting girls and how to
be a better man in general cool let me
stay around for this stuff and you know
hold on are you saying that people tune
in because they like hot chicks that
talk about drama hold on what apparently
so i didn't know yeah i didn't know this
has been hidden youtube formula for
years wow
yeah wow
but my rent what'd you do before before
doing this uh so um mark gaines 32 years
old i was a former uh special agent on
homeland secure investigations hsi um
and i did chrome investigations for
from 20 i came on as an intern in 2010 i
became an agent in 2013. i resigned uh
in 2020 of december um because basically
like you know my my youtube they're like
hey bro you got to show what are you
doing here and i was like they were
telling me yeah they brought me in and
they're like hey like you know you got
to chill with this youtube whatever
because at that point we had like 10k
and then like we're starting to build
some traction and i kind of had to make
a tough decision am i gonna resign from
the government a job that i really did
love and enjoy or am i gonna you know
pursue this entrepreneurial veteran and
i decided to go with the latter because
you know i had people depending on me
fresh was getting ready to quit his job
we had a guy our youtube guy was moving
from chicago to miami so i was like i
can't just like tell him oh go back bro
go pack back up so i was like you know
what i'll resign if you know if it
doesn't work i can always go back to the
government um but you know it was it was
a great career i have nothing bad to say
i loved it like i actually started
youtube channel where i break down cases
uh you know big celebrity cases
everything like that yeah it's called
the fed at 1811. i talked about i did
the boston marathon bombing i did the
rallo drug trafficking case and i break
it down i actually read the court
documents and go through and give people
a different perspective from like a
former agent's perspective because i
used to do these cases myself so yeah
i'm able to give a little bit of insight
but yeah that's what i did before and
then i started the youtube channel fresh
feels originally unplugged fitness it
was like a fitness channel and then we
started talking about dating we started
uh talking to whatever and then we
noticed hey we have similar
mindsets we're both womanizers let's do
a channel and then similar to a podcast
and we started doing a podcast we really
enjoyed it we talked about dating tips
and how to get girls and everything
because we're in miami both pretty good
with the ladies um but we figured it out
we weren't naturals you know a lot of
people say oh look at these two alpha
males actually you know we never talk
about being alphas we're nerds we were
guys that are words that just figured it
out so who were you in high school both
of you guys who were you know like 10th
grade 11th grade who were you in high
school man well from barbados right so
i'm an island boy coconuts you know in
the win
boy on the beach but i've been inside
for the most part playing video games
like you know online games smash
brothers mario kart with friends and
that was my life man and then what
happened was over time
started getting into like more partying
more like lifestyle and in high school
yeah okay and then after that is when i
went to like um this area in barbados
called the gap right it's like a tourist
area
and every day there's different girls
from like
canada you know uh uk from all over
germany whatever right so i'm like yo
these girls are pretty hot i started
dating those girls that were tourists
and then it opened up my mindset you
know what there's more to life than just
being on a small island i can go to the
states or whatever
and say you know what i made a goal at
least in the next five years i want to
move to america
and so said so done against america
you know made my own way worked at
chick-fil-a basically and att taking
phone calls tech support
and now we're here today the biggest
podcast in miami freshman fit so yeah um
so for me i was i was a big nerd man
like i didn't lose my virginity till i
was 18. like i played yu-gi-oh cards
growing up pokemon video games all that
stuff like uh you know i just was a guy
that kind of like figured it out and
through a lot of trial and error you
know and uh
when i hit like uh senior high school
that's when i started to like figure out
girls i read the mystery method you know
um and obviously the game these are
books i think a lot of guys start out
with the shows like figuring out how
girls operate and think um i also saw
the pickup artist which brought me which
was what like back in 2007 on vh1 that's
like kind of brought me into this whole
arena i was like oh wow like this is
crazy stuff and it was like
groundbreaking stuff that i had not
known like you got net girls all this
other stuff um and you know people talk
about puas and make fun of them or
whatever but a lot of the stuff that
they say is legit and it plays on female
psyche to put you in a positive
advantage to be more attractive so
i read that stuff was fascinated then i
went off to college i was i went to
northeast university in boston i was a
d1 athlete i wrote um and you know i
started understanding the importance of
you know social hierarchies and you know
being on a team or having some kind of
social status on campus is very
important and then once i got out of
college i was like okay well now i don't
have the social status like that anymore
what am i going to do and that's when i
kind of had to relearn everything as far
as like operating it in the real world
and then i went off to texas that's why
i was doing my career i spent several
years just like working you know season
drugs and season legal
firearms all that stuff and um and then
it wasn't until i came back to miami i
came to the miami field office at 28 and
that's when i like really like started
dialing in on like trying to like learn
how to do cold approach again learning
how to get really good women again and
then you know at that point i think we
had met when i was like 29 or 30. and i
was like you know pretty much at that
point doing really well with
ladies and you're in the scene at that
time yeah i was at the scene because
when i was in texas people don't i was
in laredo texas which for those that
don't know it's on the mexican border
there's nothing there now what i'm
saying no like absolutely nothing there
it's a small would like it he would love
it over there
but uh but i loved it man i loved living
in texas i love the radio this like a
little part of me is still there but um
when i was there i was really focused on
working and another thing too is a small
town so like you'd arrest someone and
like everyone's connected in some way so
i just didn't go out into the bars like
that whatever and you stick out like a
sore thumb because as someone who's not
mexican you know me i'm 6'3 and my
parents are from sudan i have a weird
look like you don't forget me right so
you'll see me in court like oh the hell
i know what you do so i just stayed
inside most of the time playing video
games being a loser uh and then when i
came to miami i started like getting
back out there getting back in the
dating game and you know i applied some
of the principles i had learned from
college then from the from reading and
then trial and error figured it out then
by the time me and him linked up we were
full-fledged womanizers we were figuring
out but like people try to say like oh
y'all run around and say you're alpha
males whatever it's like no actually
we're the opposite of that we just we're
just two guys that figured it out if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]